brat is in Texas hey Brad welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show thank you so much they
appreciate you taking my call sure I've
got a question for you
we just finished a class I'm newly
married six months and we took your
course right when we got married good I
came without any chat she has about 70
thousand and student loans and what I'm
trying to figure out right now is do I
help her pay off the student loans or
what we've done is I'm take care of
everything I paid off her car they don't
like you flunked you flunked the class
okay in Financial Peace University we
told you you had to combine everything
the preacher said for richer for poorer
in sickness and health unto thee all my
worldly goods I pledge this is the old
Book of Common Prayer marriage vows this
is what happens when you get married you
combine everything so she doesn't have
student loans now we have student loans
you changed your that she brought into
the marriage you change your pronouns
she doesn't have an income you have an
income we have a household income we
have assets we have liabilities we have
a combined everything and we're
attacking everything you're not doing
her a favor she's your wife you see the
difference absolutely and let me tell
you what that does it not only builds
the quality of your marriage obviously
it changes the efficiency of the math
the couples that handle money together
and are are both in couples both members
are engaged in the process we're both on
the budget we're both setting goals
together we're in agreement have the
highest probability in all of the data
we have from 30 years of doing this of
winning and becoming wealthy when one of
them drags the other one along or you're
doing that one of them a favor or
something like that or one's a princess
or whatever that kind of thing
it's almost impossible
well so combine everything knit together
knit together knit together you are one
change your pronouns sure that makes
sense yeah yeah I know it absolutely
does you know we were just thinking you
know I'm trying to or we let me change
that yeah we're trying to also max out
our Roth IRA know you know are you
advantage of that not while you're in
the get rid of all the student loans and
then do everything else
okay maybe step two is you put
everything you have on that until the
debt is gone and baby step two do you
know our payments aren't due on that
until October 2021 yes if I thought if
that's why it takes you squeeze every
dollar out of your budget until you're a
hundred percent debt free except your
home
that's baby step two do not do any
investing is that do you remember that
from the class yeah no of course
okay I mean I just wondered I was like
what I mean if we're doing something
wrong in the class because that that's
what we should be teaching and that's
what the material should have shown you
what to do so yeah you stopped all
investing you take all savings that is
non retirement and you throw it at our
debt and our income goes at our debt
until we're debt-free everything with
the house and baby step two that's the
ghazal intensity the complete focus
because your most powerful wealth
building tool is your income and when
you try to do three things at once not
not any of them get done well the power
focus is what has given us the at Ramsey
the reputation of causing people to win
with money and and that's what it comes
down to don't try to fix this it's not
broken